i
[Música]
a
francia extendió la licencia de
paternidad a partir de julio de 2021
esta pasará de 14 a 28 días actualmente
este permiso está dividido de la
siguiente manera por una parte tres días
que son pagos o por el empleador y el
resto por la seguridad social a partir
de 2021 no va a haber grandes cambios
para el empleador pero sí para la
seguridad social que se hará cargo de
los 25 días restantes este anuncio lo
hizo el presidente emmanuel alma como en
su cuenta de instagram indicando además
que estará integrada está medida dentro
de la ley de financiamiento de la
seguridad social y dijo también que
quería que siete de esos días fueran de
obligatorio cumplimiento ya que al
parecer el 70% de los padres de familia
no se toman la totalidad de esta
licencia y también porque es muy
importante que se cree un lazo precoz
entre el padre y el recién nacido todo
esto está basado en un reporte que se
entregó al gobierno por parte de un
comité de expertos en la primera
infancia el costo total de esta medida
será de 500 millones de euros anualmente
[Música]
argentina tiene una de las licencias por
paternidad más breves de la región tan
sólo dos días corridos según la ley para
dar sólo un ejemplo de otro país uruguay
da de 10 a 13 días pero el mapa real de
las licencias por paternidad en
argentina es un poco más complejo por
ejemplo el estado nacional da a sus
empleados cinco días corridos y cada
distrito puede tener su propia normativa
en la ciudad de buenos aires- los
empleados públicos reciben 15 días
corridos más 30 días a tomarse durante
el primer año de vida del bebé y los
convenios colectivos de ciertos sectores
de la economía también dan más días
incluso hay empresas del sector privado
que llegan a dar hasta meses de licencia
por paternidad pero la ley marco la ley
nacional que data de 1974 todavía lo
restringe como vimos a los dos días y
esto es algo que han intentado modificar
algunas iniciativas parlamentarias que
todavía no han dado sus frutos
[Música]
las bajas de paternidad entre los países
de la unión europea difieren mucho entre
sí mientras que los países del centro y
del norte de europa gozan de bajas
muchísimo más largas los de los países
del sur no tanto justamente para acabar
con estas disparidades luchar contra la
desigualdad de género y para que las
mujeres no tengan que decidir entre su
carrera profesional o ser madres la
unión europea hace casi dos años se
aprobó una legislación en que los padres
podían pedir un mínimo de diez días
remunerados por el nacimiento de un hijo
y un mínimo de cuatro meses para su
cuidado así las mujeres tendrían mucha
más facilidad para reincorporarse en el
mercado laboral ese es también el
objetivo de suecia un país que obliga a
los dos progenitores pedirse una baja de
al menos tres meses para el cuidado de
un hijo los expertos inciden en que este
tipo de políticas no sólo ayuda a la
conciliación familiar también ayuda a
las políticas de natalidad especialmente
importante en un continente como el
europeo con una población cada vez más
envejecida
[Música]